les manœuvres Chinoises complétées
avaient pour but d'entraîner les
militaires à imposer un blocus autour de
taïwanification est inévitable lance
porte-parole c'est l'aspiration de tout
le peuple chinois
pendant ce temps la défense nationale
taïwanaise organise ses propres
exercices simulant la défense de l'île
contre une invasion chinoise qui
déstabiliserait toute la région
c'est ce qu'on redoute depuis longtemps
à Tokyo et encore plus depuis que 5
missiles balistiques chinois ont terminé
leurs courses dans les eaux du
territoire économique japonais la
semaine dernière être entraîné dans une
guerre si il y avait une intervention
militaire américaine les troupes
américaines les plus proches de Taïwan
ne se trouve pas à Hawaï ou aguawam elle
se trouve au Japon et notamment à
Okinawa et donc une intervention
militaire américaine nécessiterait la
mobilisation des troupes américaines
basées au Japon et donc de fait une
participation directe ou indirecte du
japonais ont d'ailleurs simulé la fin de
semaine dernière une cellule de crise
afin de répondre à une invasion de
Taïwan la grande crainte et que la Chine
puisse y installer des bases militaires
à proximité du Japon ce serait la
démonstration du fait que la Chine peut
éliminer un État indépendant indépendant
de facto de la région
et donc la question se poserait japonais
c'est ce que ça pourra arriver plus tard
en Corée du Sud ou est-ce que le Japon
pourrait être victime c'est pour eux
c'est ce serait le début d'une
restructuration des relations
internationales dans la région qui
serait profondément n'est pas au Japon
le Japon ne cesse de développer son
arsenal militaire avant même la
croisement des tensions diplomatiques la
semaine dernière Tokyo envisageait de
doubler le budget de la défense ici
Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada